bonjour et merci d'être sur arte france
ce matin depuis la rentrée le 17 août
que les fermetures d'établissements se
multiplient notamment dans le chef lieu
saint denis selon un principe de
précaution face donc à l'accélération
d'épidémie est ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'on en fait trop aujourd'hui
ah non pas du tout au contraire ça fait
deux semaines que nous sommes rentrés et
on voit que l'épidémie est ce que le
virus se propage et circule et se sont
pas forcément des établissements entiers
qui sont fermés mais des classes et là
on est quand même au bout de deux
semaines à près de 34 casques ont été
fermées et près de 900 élèves qui ont
été mis en 14 n en septaine et qui vont
peut-être recommande revenir à l'école
donc lundi prochain plus d'une centaine
d'enseignants qui ont été mis aussi en
travail à distance
donc nous ne trouvons pas que nous en
faisons enfin que que les
l'administration en fait trop mais par
contre ce que nous dénonçons c'est que
la préparation je pense qu'on aurait pu
anticiper comme aurait pu se douter de
ce phénomène et anticiper peut-être
renforcer le protocole sanitaire
et pourtant le protocole sanitaire
établi par le rectorat est déjà bien
présent
lavage des mains quatre fois par jour
port du masque nettoyage daïra sont
quotidiennes des classes distanciation
si possible dans la cour de récréation
que faudrait-il faire de plus selon vous
alors tout ça c'est sur le papier parce
que distanciation s'est démarqué dans le
protocole et c'est le protocole allégée
du ministère que nous avons appliqué
nous il ya depuis deux semaines
monsieur le ministre a fait sa rentrée
entre guillemets seulement hier en
forçant un petit peu le protocole mais
depuis deux semaines la distance à sion
là elle n'est possible
il est possible que dans certains
établissements les classes continue
d'être à 35,36 la réforme du lycée n'a
rien arrangé
et surtout le ministère n'a absolument
pas entendu notre demande de personnel
puisque nous voulons plus d'effectifs
plus de personnel pour favoriser les
petits groupes
or ça n'a pas du tout été mise en place
pour cette rentrée et faire par mer ont
décidé de fermer les écoles de leur
commune est ce que c'est une décision
vous partager aujourd'hui on vous savez
nous ce que nous attendions avec un camp
mais ma passion c'était de retrouver nos
élèves retrouver les casses et je pense
que c'était partagé si l'on en croit nos
élèves mais dense est dans cet état y
dans cette inquiétude
je comprends aussi les maires qui ont
voulu prévenir parce qu'il faut prévenir
la circulation de ce virus
alors les maires qui ont fermé les
écoles on sait bien que pour les petits
les gestes barrières on voulait plus
jeune des élèves en tout cas les gestes
barrière ça n'est pas évident ça n'est
pas évident non plus pour les personnels
et puis aussi une pensée pour tous les
personnels administratifs qui ont dû
gérer au coup par coup avec des annonces
un petit peu au dernier moment là cette
rentrée donc la fermeture des écoles on
peut la comprendre parce que les gestes
barrières pour les plus jeunes des
élèves ce n'est pas très évident et on
voit bien que dans les collèges et des
lycées ça n'est pas évident non plus les
récréations ce n'est pas à distance ce
que vous vous êtes contrairement à ce
que vous avez dit dans tous les espaces
extérieurs les élèves circule maintenant
avec le masque obligatoire mais lisez
les élèves sont en contact le brassage
s'effectue dans les collèges et les
lycées parce qu'on ne peut pas faire
autrement puisque tous les élèves sont
rentrés en même temps et puis il ya le
problème aussi des transports mais on
comprenne bien
cette rentrée qui est donc effective
depuis deux semaines elle sur l'île de
la réunion elle est importante aussi
pour que les élèves puissent reprendre
normalement le cours de l'enseignement
ils sont toutefois près de 10% à être
absent aujourd'hui au quotidien comment
est-ce que les choses devraient être
désormais à mise en place selon vous
pour concilier
enseignement continue et respect des
règles sanitaires primordial alors que
on le rappelle l'épidémie est en plein
rebond
écoutez c'est très difficile je pense
que c'est très difficile de te fais pas
de leçon à donner mais c'est sûr que ce
qui nous manque c'est l'organisation en
plus petit effectif de façon à pouvoir
être au plus proche est au plus près des
élèves pour les gestes barrières et pour
revenir sur peut-être les manquements et
les inégalités qui se sont creusées du
fait du confinement et du fait de cette
longue période puisque nous certains
élèves ne sont pas revenus en classe
depuis le 8 mars dernier
non merci c'est plus plus en fait plus
d'humains pour pouvoir encadrer au mieux
et en petit effectif où monte aussi en
aménagement et vit dans des programmes
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin encore une paire est secrétaire
académique du s adressent fsu de la
réunion